[Musique]
silvia notargiacomo nous a rejoint
alors vous allez tout nous dire sur
danse avec les stars puisque vous avez
été évincé de la saison de cette
nouvelle saison de danse avec les stars
dites vous que c'est peut-être une
chance parce que vu les scores ils vont
dire que c'est peut-être parce que vous
n'êtes pas là ils vous ont évincé vous
allez nous dire comment parce que c'est
ouf comment ils ont basé du programme
vous allez voir tout ça mais juste avant
les chéris franchement qu'avez vous
pensé de la première de danse avec les
stars
je vous dit sur tous les sites médias ce
soit jean marc morandini aux as où sont
dit que vraiment perdre un million de
téléspectateurs benjamin comment vous
expliquer alors moi je sais pas comment
on peut l'expliquer peut-être que le
clat la très belle météo a fait que les
gens sont sortis peut-être peut-être à
mais alors il ya juste les mecs qui
regardent était là oui mais j'aimerais
que tout le monde à rester au même
niveau
moi je suis pas de ce fait d'accord avec
vous je pense que le casting c'est
sélection c'est pas des stars mais je
faisais le plus homogène qui vais jamais
fait
visuellement c'est pas dégueulasse
honnêtement après moi je n'aime je
n'aime pas le principe de l'émission
j'ai vu deux personnes très bien danser
c'est le l'espagnol signer les autres
franchement il ya des nuits relater ce
qui était d'une tristesse absolue et ça
ne savez pas danser du tout comme les
jours bouteflika car là vous allez nous
de votre ami et kelly juste votre avis
vous parce que vous êtes un peu la cible
de danse avec les stars
si vous avez ou pas justement moi qui se
fait la 6e j ai regardé avec des copines
aucun nous intéresse on les connaît pas
à part arielle dombasle que je trouve
aussi marrante rigolote mais à ce moment
là au moins les autres nous intéresse
pas je pense qu'il faut être passionné
de danse pour regarder sa rançon
non mais là les cherry et il n'y a pas
que passionné dont il fallait serrer
qu'elle a un peu raison là vous croyez
vraiment qu'il ya des gens qui disent
[ __ ] y'a mon favori qui va danser
l'année dernière il y avait quand même
du bon alors on va revenir
l'actionnement oui j'ai déjà vous avez
donné votre avis aussi sur le casting
vous allez nous dire s'il ya des des
danseurs qui sont avantagés par rapport
à d'autres
s'il ya des magouilles au niveau des
votes ce comment ils vous ont viré tf1
enfin elle nous dira tout et vous aurez
une grosse révélation à nous faire sur
danse avec les stars vous dira tout dans
un instant c'était la première samedi
les chérit plus mauvais démarrage et
c'est vrai que c'est voilà c'est un très
très beau show au gros show de la en
production je pense que c'est le truc le
mieux produit
voilà aujourd'hui en terme de show et en
direct après ils ont un casting les gars
c'est quand même une tana ce qui à
chaque fois toute la soirée était obligé
trop te retourner voilà c'est qui ça
ferait un peu dallas julia vignali est
avec nous mais le meilleur pâtissier
c'est de 28 alors à des images et je
suis dit que je lui dis à viña litres
dans le meilleur pâtissier ciel qui
reprend le flambeau et elle va être
formidable et je te dis je sais que
c'est l'émission qui cartonne le plus
sur m6 mais je sais bien que ça va
encore plus cartoon avec toi mais
jusqu'à bien mais je vais tout faire
pour cyril est tu sais ça fait combien
de temps que je te dis que tu es
formidable c'est vrai que ça fait un
certain nombre d'années mais tout le
monde le dit n'est pas aussi fort que
toi et tu vois et voilà si tu as entendu
m6 m'a tendu s'est vite malheureusement
donc on va parler de la faute du
meilleur pâtissier en plus les pattes de
musique et on fera un gros gros plainte
est non je la réponse tout à leurs
intérêts je pense que ça va être très
très très très beau parce qu'elle est
inquiète aussi
julia sa marie voyer de passer du bon
son c'est yarah bravo c'est quoi alors
alors elle ça fait huit ans que la
patience
[Rires]
elle en fait c'est comme le mec demi
seront installés derrière un ordi alors
pour nous bretons continuent c'est pas
vrai basilan c'est un truc g20 merci oui
et pas mal pas mal l'animal le toit
quand même les cherry dans mais c'est
vrai julia que c'est quand on nous dit
jet carole son tour carole saint-ours
qu'on évite savez 45 tours à la de
l'esprit malade décide lui même beaucoup
est-ce que tu regardes danse avec les
stars
ah oui j'adore ça non c'est vrai mais
vraiment je suis épaté j'aimerais le
faire
non surtout pas mais je suis en plus au
drame que tu vois c'est qu'avec le
meilleur pâtissier tu vas être un poil
trop connu ma chérie la nasa va partir
en cacahuète alors lis chéri et puis je
vais vous parler d'un pays que j'aime
beaucoup c'est vincent cerrutti vinson
quai pendant plusieurs saisons a
coprésenté danse avec les stars
et maintenant il est candidat et on a un
petit extrait de sa prestation ce que je
voulais le voir danser
vincent en garde
ce ton
du sang
[Musique]
est-ce que tu m'attendre
mandela ou je ne sais pas
on va pas se cacher techniquement c'est
une catastrophe
mais vous ne m'avez jamais vu danser
même à l'époque où j'étais avec vous
faire et sandrine une fois ma vue danser
c'était une catastrophe alors qu'il est
passé d'animateur à danseurs vincent
cerrutti la prochaine fois il montre le
décor est fait quoi dresser sa chute pas
la première fois ni matters deuxième
fois dans ces antres de faire des gens
mais alors moi je vais vous dire moi
j'ai un coup de gueule alors j'ai un
coup de gueule contre la production il
faut tourner les animateurs ils vont
faire donc là sténico se devait de
mettre une note d'ailleurs à nico sur sa
prestation la semaine prochaine c'est
que le cheval de chemin des stocks de
chavannes faut concevoir bogard il
aurait dû reprendre vincent cerrutti
parce qu'ils trouvaient pas d'animateur
il se fait très bien
benjamins non je suis d'accord et
honnêtement c'est courageux de sa part
d'avoir écrit de danse et après pourquoi
ils n'ont pas mis avec les autres c'est
ça il voulait le couple ils sont ratés
bizarre aussi qu'ils reviennent alors
qu'il a déjà présenté l'émission
hélas il était moins gourmand on a passé
en numéro 10 mais qu'est c'est comme si
moi demain l'année prochaine sur la tête
de ma mère dans touche pas à mon poste
je présente plus l'émission mais ces
huit il met dans une cabine à bluff sk
scianna avec une jmar acabit la bloss
les gars parce qu'il peut le faire il le
faisait très bien
bon vous souvenez que jamais dit de la
sanch et rupture je me souviens de vous
on aurait dit qu'il avait une tringle
dans le derrière et ben là je me suis
dit tiens qu'est ce que ça va donner
d'eux que effectivement maintenant on va
le voir sur le terrain moi ça m'amusait
beaucoup de le voir sur le terrain et du
coup je pensais tellement que ce serait
catastrophique donc c'est un peu moins
catastrophique et le catastrophique que
j'attendais peut-être qu'il va y gagner
parce que moi je les trouvais très
touchant ya des gens qui vous donne la
parole
mais vous avez raison allez-y vous avez
tous les droits ben voilà en fait je
disais que peut-être qu'il va y gagner
parce qu'effectivement il avait cette
image très lisse et de joindre un peu
idéale un peu fadasse
oui moi je les trouvais assez touchant
ing non moi ça m'a pas plus justement
j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu la
critique doit émettre c'est le coup
place à toucy et vincent cerruti
je les trouves comment dire dans un peu
un programme de télé réalité je trouve
que la mise en scène de leur histoire
d'amour de leur couple je voudrais hors
sujet par rapport au programme
alors pourquoi ça marche pas dit la
vérité ça fait kapinos en vous car là
qui est la plus jeune des kings avec
elle 23 23 ans vous devriez être
normalement le pub
en plus votre papa a fait danser avec
les stars est il dans sexy bien ouais
alors bon souvenir de david ginola ou
pas en tant que danseur peut-être un
intrus beaux souvenirs parce que c'est
un compétiteur c'est un acharné du
travail
et là je peux toucher les mocassins
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs c'est parti en finale
non vous avez fait qu' alors c'est qui
pour tous les gars qui ont dansé goût
harel a souffert on est sûr de voir
alors n'hésitez plus et venez vite vous
avez qui fait ou pas alors allez-y david
ginola a donc préféré
oui vous dis pas ça parce que safin
mayonnade comme david ginola pour son
côté compétitif
ouais ensuite deuxième saison francis
lalanne oui j'aime bien moi alors
ensuite à la brune classe balmont très
classe très dire alors psychologiquement
surtout très accord troisième enfin
gérard vivès gérard vivès un très drôles
que d'autres est très drôle ça a été
très dur avec lui mais je me suis bien
nagé pendant votre deuxième préférées
non si ces montres c'est mon deuxième
fois après y'a que des caps add on rails
à titeuf koné qui est il serait alors
très très sympa mais c'est vrai que dans
la densité pas non c'est pas son délire
mais bien il est très sympa c'est un
amour après anthony kavanagh way sympa
aussi très très sympa d'accord c'est
sympa finalement way et l'eau est
ensuite hissé à oui lille mon pote ou
alors ayez ce magnifique dommage qu'il
avait un problème à la hanche
du coup ils attendaient une prothèse
piochera sur sa gauche veut vraiment
dommage dommage dommage à lorient 1 0 je
suis allée peine ensuite j'ai alors
julien lepers drôle comment ils sont
choisis les danseurs par rapport aux
personnalités qu est ce qu a des dents à
ce qu'à des personnalités qui sont
avantagés dit la vérité ou est ce que
c'est vous qui dessine alors je ne sais
pas s'ils sont avantagés ou pas on ne
peut pas décider parce que j'aurais
jamais choisi de danser avec julien
lepers
pourtant si qui avait déjà des bases de
danse plus que jamais chaque année quand
vous désigner votre partenaire vous
disais bon c'est bon j'ai encore perdu
cette année quoique c'est ça oui c'était
que dans la liste je regardais et c'est
vrai que quand j'avais la liste des
participants je me disais
lequel est loin bon c'est sûr que les
pombas celui-là alors pourquoi tf1 vous
a évincé du programme il parait il
paraît que vous aurez 20 c est pareil
vous avez fait tout tout les voilà les
castings qui a travaillé pour jusqu'au
match et chorégraphies ouais et après
vous envoyez un sms
on arrête tout près non si c'est par sms
vous ont dû porter un couple d'ados
aquitain a wave aujourd'hui on arrête
vous aviez fait une bêtise
non pas du tout j'ai travaillé avec eux
je disais jusqu'au mois de juillet pour
eux pour faire le cap pour le casting de
la saison 8
d'accord et puis on a envoyé un joli
texto pour me dire qu' il n'y avait pas
de partenaire pour moi ce que je
comprends pas parce qu'il ya du
partenaire pour les autres états pour
moi parce que vous parce que vous avez
fait le casting avec lenny kim vous
deviez dans ces cliniques him non non
vous deviez dans ce big ben je ne sais
pas en tout cas j'ai fait le casting de
lemmy et de suite investi exactement
derrière et donc ils vous ont remplacé
par qui par une nouvelle danseuse ce qui
en fait elle s'appelle à juba famille
après je ne sais pas s'ils m'ont
vraiment remplacer en tout cas elle fait
partie des des castings est ce que c'est
vrai que les danseurs enfin les nouveaux
danseurs qui sont pas assez bons pour
danser donc ils ont des profs de danse
en plus c'est à dire que aj bas qui est
une très très grande danseuse et je
connais depuis très longtemps
ouais elle est très bonne dans son
domaine c'est à dire les danses
contemporaine modern jazz hip hop danse
de clips mais je ne la connais pas du
tout du monde de la danse de sportive la
danse à deux le cha cha la salle avec ou
encore du bon alors c'est bien qu'on lui
a payé
la production lui a payé quand même un
prof de danse pendant trois mois comme
quoi en trois mois on peut apprendre ce
que j'ai appris pendant 25 ans vous êtes
déçu très déçu c'est vrai papa non
puisque sk dsk des personnalités qui
sont mises en avant et est ce que dit la
vérité franchement ce sens qui sont mis
en avant par rapport à des magnétos par
rapport à comment ils sont là on a est
ce que la prod dit parce que et on sait
qu'il ya des contrats qui sont signés
dans danse avec les stars
et il ya des gens qui disent moi je peux
rester que trois semaines donc quoi
qu'il arrive avant trois semaines
il faut que faut que ce soit dehors
est-ce que ça arrive ça donc qu'on se
dise bon lui il va falloir l'éliminer
donc moi je pense que tout le monde
n'est pas non plus dispute ne seront pas
disponibles pendant trois mois je pense
qu'il ya parmi eux qui ont déjà des
contrats à côté alors tu donc évoqué il
ya donc il ya des trucs qui sont déjà
joués il ya des gens ils s'inscrivaient
et bah oui et non je ne sais pas si
c'est vraiment jouer mais peut-être
qu'ils font en sorte de ne pas trop les
mettre en avant par rapport au choix de
miss burkina
oui mais alors ces nouvelles
informations parce que concernant les
grosses stars pour les alpaguer parfois
ici soit deux ou trois prime comme ça
qu'il aime avec une sortie de secours
prévu je pense ça a été le cas dans les
filets winter c'était le cas de djibril
cissé
c'est sûrement le cas de notre ami
arielle dombasle et après le prime
supplémentaire c'est entre 1500 et 2500
euros supplémentaires par semaine
voilà mais en tout cas ils ont des
clodos deux ans qu'il ya des gens qui je
peux rester que trois semaines et donc
ils sont ils sont foutus dehors total
arrêts de jeu voilà vous même combien
payez un danseur de danse avec les stars
pour le fait d'une petite [ __ ]
c'est un dixième d'une célébrité même
pas alors je sais pas une célébrité sait
comment ça détend je peux pas dire les
célébrités ne sont pas payés tout le
même prix donc eu un sessad ok paraît
que c'est entre eux je crois que c'est
entre 50000 et trois cent mille euros
c'est ça maximum mauvaise découvre toute
la saison et donc ouais je crois que
c'est ça ouais je me suis trompé de
métier la fête célébrant chez vous
pouvez passer oui non mais sans être
naïf on peut pas aujourd'hui se rendre
compte que le monde de la télé est
cruelle et injuste et c'est la loi
pendant sept ans quand vous avez été
danseuse
vous avez aussi lui peut-être des
agissements comme ça et pour autant vous
à crest et vous n'avez rien dit vous
n'allez pas dénoncer parce que c'est
vrai que c'est c'est une très belle
émission moi j'adore danser donc tout ce
qui coûte j'adore danser même si là vous
mettez une musique et vous dites danser
je vais faire je voulais venir avec moi
le da mois
dans une pensée
[Musique]
ap
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va dire un truc intéressant avec la
séduction féminine vous aimez vous aimez
faire le premier pas mais vous n'êtes
vous n'aimez pas qu'on la famille c'est
pourquoi je vais être que des pas en
arrière mon jour mon nom
[Applaudissements]
on a vu ce qui se passe le temps en
temps dans 12 ans a créé star c'est que
la personnalité est assez passive après
étape danseurs qui fait le show room et
comme c'est bien filmé on a l'impression
qu'ils bougent beaucoup mais c'est l'âge
est là je vous ai ten julien lepers